hi this is Penn Jillette of Penn &
Teller I'll be answering your questions
from Twitter this is a magic support the
magicians are not supposed to reveal
their secrets how do you get new
magicians it's a stupid rule we could
not agree more we've been thrown out of
the Magic Circle and the Magic Castle
for giving away magic secrets giving
away magic secrets or rather not giving
away magic secrets is not a moral rule
it's a compositional rule when you're
starting out and you're doing the trick
for somebody and afterwards they say how
did you do that if you tell them the
whole lusion crumbles it's not a good
idea to tell them when you're a beginner
when you become more professional
sometimes giving away a little bit of a
secret helps you sell another secret
later down the line and certainly when
you're teaching people like in our
master class or our books you'll give
away secrets that's the way people learn
it's a stupid rule because it doesn't
exist let's see what's next Chris
Hastings how often dependent teller mess
up a stage illusion happening sort to
the hidden shadow sorcery to make sure
no one notices you know the stuff we're
doing often pretends to be dangerous
it's often dealing with subjects that
are dangerous and therefore would be
immoral to have something be really
dangerous you should not go to an
entertainment expecting someone to get
hurt so because we work with stuff that
is apparently dangerous we have to be
very very careful so very rarely do
things screw up at that kind of
monumental level and when they do we do
not resort to the dark powers we take
our lumps we take responsibility we just
say we screw it up next Kevin Sokka how
do magicians eat glass without injuring
themselves that's not a magic trick it's
a geek trick there are a few things that
make it easier in terms of diet and
preparation which I'm not going to tell
you I'm afraid if I explain a little bit
about eating glasses someone might try
it and it's a very very dangerous trick
even done properly so don't try it
what's the etiquette when a magic tree
doesn't
should I pretend like it worked or
should I be honest it depends on how it
doesn't work a lot of times honesty is a
good idea but if you part of it worked
get away with it and if something
accidental happens to happen then they
should look good well don't be surprised
just go on we were doing a seance at
Steven Spielberg's bachelor party and
there was this one moment when I had to
do a force which means the spectator
thinks they have a free choice but
actually you're forcing a choice upon
them if I wanted you to pick the three
of spades for instance I could say just
tell me when to stop and when to stop
and I would say right about there okay
you picked the three of spades now
that's a sleight-of-hand way to do a
force no I had a slight of hand weighted
to a force of all these pictures we had
and Spielberg decided to just grab a
picture and say this is the one I want
now that is a major screw-up if I say
I'm gonna have you pick a card and you
just go give me this one well I haven't
had time to force it I'm completely
screwed up but Steven Spielberg happened
to pick the picture I was going to force
so I got really really lucky and it
turned out that that trick was
impossible to explain just because he
screwed it up what have we got next
Anthony says a serious moral question of
magicians when a sick kid asks you is
magic real do you tell them the truth or
lie that is a serious moral question is
a serious moral answer there's no such
thing as magic there's no such thing as
a supernatural and I don't care if it's
a sick child or a healthy adult you do
not lie I never ever want to leave
someone believing that magic is real
that would be morally wrong Darrin
Gendron is going to put to question for
magicians when working with a card deck
how many copies the deck do you like
having to work with I guess it's how
many copies of a trick deck would you
like having to work with it's the same
question with anything how many new
guitar strings you want to have around
when you're playing guitar seriously
fencing how quickly they wear out now
roughly you play and what gage stringer
using same thing with the different cars
than to what you're doing if you're
doing simple stuff you know it's not
gonna make any difference if you're
doing heavy duty
you know Pharoah shuffles and this kind
of stuff you're gonna want a very very
new deck they all go together very
nicely question or magicians will
technology eventually render levitation
effects trivial no you're not going to
get levitation out of technology for a
really really long time
that's my prediction also you do get
levitation you get a very different kind
of levitation I used to be magicians
were on the forefront of technology
because communication is so good now and
everybody knows technology so well you
can no longer sell sell magic with
technology so even if technology is able
to do limited levitations the long
version the magic version I believe will
still be interesting at least for a
while
at least for my lifetime but I'm wicked
old Stephen Blair there's a name I can
pronounce Stephen Blair this tweet will
only make sense to a few people question
egytian z-- do you file the size of your
debt before using it this is for real
advanced cardistry stuff for someone
like Richard Turner who is a card wizard
not only does it matter exactly how the
sides are sanded or filed but he also
needs to have them printed just right
now Richard Turner is blind and does
everything by touch and is exact what we
call the work in the deck slight little
bends on the corners that he can feel
the work he does with those are so
subtle that his cards have to be
absolutely perfect so after you get to
deck of cards he does a lot of rubbing
on a surface all the surface to get all
the little burrs off the edges to be
able to do everything right and do all
the fanning and I've never done anything
that complicated I do a palm I do a pass
into a few other moves but I'm not good
so my decks of cards can be pretty much
run out of the box but yeah we're to get
into heavy-duty magic with cards or
cardistry you
have to be you have to have them just
perfect of course we're doing card
cheating you got to work with every gut
and how does a magician know if their
invisible ink pen is out of ink when
they are writing all I will say there
you misspelled there oh Jesus Christ
Rai Bray where did we just get those
little smoke bombs they throw down to
disappear I'm gonna need a couple of
those today it does bring up an
interesting point in in the old Batman
television show not the Batman that's
all all conflicted but the Adam West's
Batman of the 60s they would have
villains but throw down a throw down
something from a runaway that's just a
movie
magic trick that's not done in the real
world sometimes smoke is used to obscure
stuff but pretty much it's one of those
things that if you can think of it it
won't fool you and if rye bra can think
of this it's not gonna fool anybody
Penny Lane how does the magician pull a
rabbit out of a hat who puts it in there
is it hungry how does it fit in there
does it have a girlfriend I can't sleep
until I learn this okay let's take them
magicians pull a rabbit out of a hat
usually by not pulling out of the Hat
usually loaded in right before it's
usually in a bag it's usually hung
inside you it fits in there usually a
body load for not all the time usually a
body loader than you you would show the
Hat empty good cop it here load it in
black bag open it up pulled it out the
rabbits in the black bag for maybe 90
seconds and the rabbit is transferred in
maybe two seconds we used to do that
trick our rabbit would happily run into
the back in like that little closed
space yes they would have a girlfriend
or a boyfriend or any sort of friend
they wanted we would have a little
little area for the rabbits where they
were very comfortable and happy and
Penny Lane I hope you sleep now
TR MJ which is the real mrs. Jeffy just
came across fool us with Penn Jillette
and mr. teller I'm trying to figure out
how do you even begin to fool them in
magic well you know there are really
good magicians and although teller and I
have over a hundred years of magic
experience between us there are people
who are
really clever and really really smart
and really really well rehearsed and
they fool the living out of us Daniel so
now that I'm an uncle I should probably
learn how to do a magic trick or
something right yes you should you part
of your job as an uncle is to do stupid
magic tricks they don't have to be good
you can take a ball like this you can
say you know I'm gonna be able to show
you this trick right here make it vanish
and your little nephew and niece will
just love it Amanda asks I need someone
to tell me how magicians do the trick
where they put phones inside glass
bottles help me it's keeping me awake at
night a lot of problems with insomnia on
on Twitter as we see with our president
phone inside the glass bottle I believe
is a trick that's still being used
professionally I did not develop it I
did not invent it I believe it's still
for sale I don't think it's within my
rights to tell you how that's dumb but
it's a wicked good trick oh and you're
not going to sleep how do the magician
swallow bunches of razor blades without
hurting felt very very repulsive it's a
form of sleight of hand don't think you
can swallow razor blades would be okay
you can't you will die don't do it
Jeremy the sofa King I've always had a
fear of cracking an egg open and having
a baby shape and pop out like a magician
how do magicians work past that what
baby chicks do come out of eggs that's
not magic that's nature oh man the
rubberband up the nose magic tree didn't
work I hit my wrist really really hard
sorry
Globo how does the magician entertain
the magician with the magic yeah
magicians would love to see magic you
don't you know it's out as a guitar
player entertain another guitar player
by guitar playing musicians like music
just as much as non musician and
magicians like magic more than non
logicians our whole show fool us is all
about magicians doing magic for us and
trying to fool us and we love it
thank everybody on Twitter for your
questions long try to hit one of the
lens there we go